brussel sprouts get too much
hate I love brussels sprouts so much
love Brussels I made brussels sprouts
you made brussels sprouts I made
brussels sprouts we had um a
Thanksgiving in Budapest when we were
shooting um P things and uh Mark made
his famous brussel sprouts and they were
excellent thank you we love brussels
sprouts yes there were pine nuts in
there pine nuts there Sprouts yeah yeah
you little devil thank
you what an interesting thing in the
morning yeah I know they have a little
butter on them oh they do mhm okay mhm
how do these compare to Marks they're a
little Bland no offense but marks are
better but these are good I took a bit
of offense to that I'm not going to lie
they're you had it coming